mélanie vient de recevoir son compte de
carte de crédit
les fêtes ont coûté cher son compte
s'élève à 2500 dollars el pais 2400 $
pour les 100 dollars reste à saillir
arbres reprocher mais le mois suivant
mauvaise surprise on lui réclame plus de
33 dollars en frais d'intérêt c'est
beaucoup dit elle pour une dette de
seulement 100 $ pendant un mois
mais les nids se trompent les intérêts
ne sont pas calculés sur 100 dollars
mais bien sûr sa dette totale de 2500 $
chaque fois que milani utilise sa carte
de crédit la banque prête de l'argent
sans aucun intérêt les il ya une
condition
elle doit payer son compte au complet à
sa date d'échéance
comme mélanie n'a pas respecté cette
condition les avantages de ce prêt sans
intérêt ne s'applique plus il tout cela
est parfaitement légal
un mode histoire payés atteint est au
complet
c'est dans votre intérêt